Wanda, hmm is there something special about today
well i know the apron is a bit much dear but i
am doing my best to blend in no no they're on
the calendar someone's drawn a little heart
right above today's day oh yes the heart
well don't tell me you have forgotten
Vis forgotten oh Wanda, i'm incapable of
forgetfulness i remember everything
that's not an exaggeration in fact
i'm incapable of exaggeration well then tell
me what's so important about today's date
what was the question again oh wow perhaps you've
forgotten yourself hey heavens no i've been
so looking forward to it as haha today we are
celebrating you bet we are it's the first time
we have ever celebrated this occasion before
it's a special day perhaps an evening great
significance to us naturally obviously exactly
well done us. Marvel studios first original series
arrives on disney plus wanda and vision we are in
uncharted waters we just don't know what to expect
westview's our home now I want us to fit
in we shall wanda, have you gotten bigger?!
life moves pretty fast out in the suburbs
You're the avengers are you here to
help us why would you think that
who are you I don't know
I think something's wrong here
This is our home then let's fight for it
marvel studios Wandavision an original series
streaming friday exclusively on disney plus
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
marvel Wandavision episode one video they just
released a bunch of new scenes obviously we'll
break this down but they also were talking about
what's going on with the later episodes and some
of the other marvel disney plus series so i'll
explain that during the video i'll be doing videos
for all the episodes starting this friday we're
getting the first two episodes on friday as well
but after that it will be weekly episodes through
episode nine there are nine episodes total in
Wandavision so if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos and i will
keep doing the disney plus membership giveaway
as we go along all you have to do to enter that
is just be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Wandavision easter eggs you've seen so far on the
video speaking of which you probably noticed this
very deadpool moment here where scarlet witch
turns to the camera and addresses the audience
breaking the fourth wall so it sounds like
she's going to be doing that very deadpool thing
breaking the fourth wall during the series as well
but obviously this opening scene here is just the
i love lucy joke about them both forgetting why
they're so hyped up about the august 23rd date
the heart on the date represents exactly what you
think it does they kind of imply that during this
scene here even though it's them just playing
up the comedy of this moment like neither one
of us actually remembers what's going on here
we're doing something very special for the very
first time the series obviously is parodying
sitcoms in the 1950s in this particular episode
along with a little bit of bewitch which is 1960s
just because of the way she uses her powers the
way they visualize that but unlike sitcoms of
that actual period the Wandavision episodes
like you would expect continue the plot from one
episode to the next in serialized story fashion
so they actually do pay off this quote unquote
special date later on you actually see that unfold
like in the other trailer footage you see them
talk about being married but not having rings or
having a song or an anniversary then you see
them in the 1960s bewitched in dick van dyke
episode seen in the beds then she uses her powers
to combine them so they can finally get it on and
make them some x-men babies so there's a lot of
setup and payoff with the jokes that they have in
these first couple of episodes vision's dialogue
here at the end if you couldn't make out what he
says there right at the end he says well done us
like he's congratulating both of them for being so
awesome despite the fact that neither one of them
can remember what they're supposed to be doing for
the first time wink wink the footage is a little
too grainy and it's not 4k so it's kind of hard
to read a lot of the labels on the products and
the things in the background too but you have to
remember that a lot of this is very carefully
designed so a lot of the logos and a lot of the
names of things are also mcu easter eggs the name
of the newspaper is the westview herald because
that's the name of the town that they live in
west view this sort of fictional twilight zone
alternate reality where she lives kind of like
a god she can kind of do whatever she wants here
create anything that she wants but because this
is meant to be the 1950s in this particular
scene you see a very 1950s sounding headline here
little baby june's first word tickles mother sue
so as you probably guessed all these references
to babies the heart the date on the calendar the
special anniversary that they've marked for
themselves and then them in the beds later is
all about them and their children getting it on
so that they can actually have some children and
if you read the tom king vision run a lot of you
actually asked me in earlier videos to point out
the tom king references because obviously that's
mostly about vision creating family for himself
but also tom king wrote a story very much like
this where vision and scarlet witch get it on
and of course as you would expect things totally
totally get weird i do love the way that they work
a lot of the mcu humor and references to present
day stuff like it's very anachronistic vision says
you know i'm actually capable in forgetting
because he's an android then another very i
love lucy joke that's not an exaggeration
because i'm also incapable of exaggeration
even though technically that's not true he can
lie as much as he wants to it's just that this
twilight zone alternate reality version of him
vision that scarlet witch creates is meant to be
exactly like she remembered him or if she wanted
him to be and he was always capable of lying forms
of deceit telling jokes even but it was a very
data-like star trek spin on him doing those things
like he was learning to do those things emulate
more human personality traits when you rewatch
that scene from avengers infinity war right before
the black order comes to take the mind stone from
him he actually seems very very human the way paul
bettany is performing him and he's used his powers
to make himself look like a full-blown human
like actual real-life paul bettany for those of
you also asking about the mind stone too like is
it back because she creates a brand new infinity
stone how does that work so the reason why this
version of vision inside this reality has the mind
stone is because scarlet witch can create anything
inside this alternate reality the real test though
i think is going to be whether or not when they
start to blend realities this one aspects of it
with the main mcu reality in the last couple of
episodes if vision will still be able to have the
mind stone and if it will still have its full
power of a regular infinity stone because that
is the most op power that you could ever have the
ability to effectively create new infinity stones
in alternate realities and then bring them whole
into the main mcu reality if you're not a big
comic book reader they actually have rules about
how that works in the comics that prevent people
from doing things like that so even if this
version of vision from this reality is able to
come back to the main mcu reality whole and still
be himself with the mind stone in his forehead
it won't have the true infinity stone level
powers it'll be severely limited or it won't
have his cosmic level powers it'll be more like
the sunstone comic book vision has in his forehead
in the comics vision doesn't have an infinity
stone in his forehead it's just like a regular
sun stone that helps power him up in normally
in the comics infinity stones from alternate
realities or alternate universes of the multiverse
don't work in other people's universes they only
work in the universe that they were created
in but then all the 1970s talk about them not
knowing what to expect obviously is a reference
to the twin x-men children because at this point
it's after the scene where he's like wanda you've
gotten bigger because she is super pregnant i know
you all want to see what billy and tommy wicken
and speed are going to look like they've been very
careful to omit all footage of them when they're
older but obviously as you go through the decades
of television they age up that's why they're
going through the decades of sitcoms so they can
age the children up to teenagers by the end of the
series there are easter eggs for everything in the
background here with set design too you notice
in the background of the 1970s the highlight
colors around the background here are the colors
of the infinity stones and a lot of the patterns
are references to either mcu things or things
specific to scarlet witch and vision like when
they're in this 80s 90s scene here like the full
house looking scene of them holding the babies
you see this blue star over here remember the mind
stone was encased in a blue gemstone when it was
being used in loki's scepter we also get to see
that really cool upgraded version of vision using
his mind stone powers to alter his appearance back
to his true self like the minute that agnes here
which is her name on the tv show even though i
think we all believe that she's playing a version
of agatha harkness she references the avengers
and starts making fun of him for being dead and it
looks like he just automatically transforms back
into his regular self and then floats into the
sky but she's dressed like the wicked witch of the
west because this is all meant to be the halloween
part of the episode where he's walking around in
the halloween version of his comic book costume
they did tune up their avengers costumes a little
bit too because you also see scarlet witch wearing
a slightly tuned up version of her modern day
avengers costume in the later footage from the
more modern parts of the episodes but it looks
like they're actually having a full-blown battle
against the sword agents and speaking of comic
book costumes if you haven't been watching a
lot of the social media posts that they've been
doing on all the marvel accounts they've actually
been releasing posters for all the characters
and some of the monica rambo posters have her
in versions of her comic book photon costume it's
hard to tell which era this takes place during
but this card kind of makes it seem like this
is the modern day version of her sword uniform
and really cool easter egg too that we found out
from some of the logos and the tie-in materials
the actual acronym for sword means something
different in the mcu than it does in the comics
so on the tv show apparently it means sentient
weapon observation research division so vision
for instance is a sentient weapon scarlet witch is
a sentient weapon so it seems like in the mcu the
whole reason nick fury creates the sword agency is
to keep an eye on super individuals or artificial
intelligence is like vision they haven't actually
confirmed nick fury cameo during this but they did
say that obviously Wandavision is going to connect
to spider-man 3 of all things which i thought was
a big surprise but doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness even elizabeth olsen was talking
about working with sam raimi and how that was
different she didn't give away any huge spoilers
but there will be easter eggs for doctor strange
too stuff in setup teasers things that happened
during Wandavision so i'll just point those out
during the episodes when they actually happen
but my Wandavision episode 1 and episode 2
video will post friday just like normal so
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff if you have
any big questions or requests during my episode
videos just let me know in the comments as well
congratulations lance wright you're the giveaway
winner from my last big marvel video please email
me on the about page of my channel so i can get
your contact details everyone click here for that
new marvel loki trailer video and click here for
that other really big Wandavision episode 1 scene
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!